The relationship
between scholarship
and the political world
seems to me an essential one
because so much of what
scholarly inquiry involves is
understanding ourselves
and our place in the world
and the foundations for
advancing human goals
within that world, and so
to be able to share some
of the details of that,
the approaches to that,
the changing understanding
of that, whether it's
in of course the natural
sciences where we see it
so directly, but also
in the human sciences
where policy matters
are gonna turn out much
to be much more effective if
they're rooted in real research
and deep understanding.